Casey, you're making us feel like
shamed cause you're wearing pants. Mind,
it's just take them off, but I
couldn't. I'm with my opening that gate.
That's a tactic. That's what that is.
Yeah. That's a tactic. Yeah. What kind of,
what do you mean? It's a tactic
that trying to like, come on man,
show us your Dick.
This is how you show everyone you dick.
You get together with five of your buddies
and you all are real comfortable with
seeing each other's dicks.
Right? And we're good.
We're going to get to see Mikey's Dick.
How are you going to do that?
I'm going to shame them.
We're going to shame him in this showing
us his dick and we're going to take our
dicks out. We're going to walk into that
steam room. I just gonna let it get nuts.
Hang. Why does anyone want to see
what the fuck are you doing with your,
but take your goddamn pants off and he'll
be like, go roller door road. Jesus.
Why does everyone want see Mikey so bad?
Cause Mike,
you probably has a little Dick. Which
that's enough. That's what I felt like.
I felt like everybody thinks I have a
small one because I got my pants up,
but that's not it. Um,
purely for research purposes.
I was online the other night
googling into Dick Surgery,
Dick and large and surgery. It was after
that billionaire guy actually died. What?
Yeah, he was a diamond dealer. He was in
his sixties, and I want to say it was,
I don't know, it was in
Europe or somewhere. Anyway,
homeboy got some Dick Surgery.
Lance died on the operating table.
Wow. I didn't even know they're
doing that. She googled it.
Surgery. Yeah. You don't,
you don't let my grandmother had a saying
don't let anyone mess with your eyes
or your Dick. Yeah, there
it is. He goes, uh, the,
the gentleman had been high
where you're going. Um,
he had a heart attack in
the middle of the procedure,
which isn't Fda approved and then
it says, is it safe? Dun, Dun, Duh.
I think anytime you go under,
it's not 100% safe. Hey,
anytime putting you under
and cutting you open.
I went under for the first time last
month. It was an aesthetic deaths.
It's from the anesthetic. That's what I'm
saying. Yeah. They put you wonder man,
you could fucking die. I know. I was
worried about and he's an older fellow.
I think that guy was in his sixties
includes surgical lengthening,
which involves cutting
a ligament. Ah, hey.
At the base of the penis or filler
injections. I'll go with filler.
Let's see what you do with filler first.
Then if I'm going to cut my
deck that later, stage two,
they're going to use a
filler caulking on foam.
You spray into the installation
and they come through the asshole.
What does this implant
for men? Ah Gee. Whoa.
There ball clicked. I don't know.
Fall into, hold on. Hold on.
You're going to shove plastic and your
Dick. Is that what that guy has? Yeah,
like a sling. Oh, hold on. Go Low. Stop.
Stop, stop, stop, stop. Stop scrolling.
Pay. No, no, no. Look at this thing
you have. You could pick your side.
It's a sleeve. It's like a sleeve.
You didn't show that Dick on TV stuff.
That's just for you guys.
Well, it pull it up, bro.
Work. They, they can stick the extra long
click. What if you're like, oh my God.
Oh my God, this is so good. Ah.
[inaudible] it looks like
a little piece of gutter.
A small incision just above the base of
the penis where your pubes are and the,
okay. Then they slide it down
into your shaft. I got, I
got one word for everybody.
What is it? Infection. Ah, what have
you got? A Dick Infection. Oh my God.
I have one word for you.
Popular
to think that works.
Implant secured now hidden sutures,
which are generally not detectable
by a patient or whatever. Oh,
so you have like this
sleeve inside the skin.
I'll tell you what's going on now though.
In Porn. This is some real shit. They,
they have day of Gmo
definitely takes an hour.
There's Gmo Dick's now.
Well your way bigger.
I was watching that old
porn film with John Holmes.
Well we were kids. John Holmes
was the guy with the biggest debt.
John Holmes has a regular deck compared
to porn stars for real especially.
And this sounds racist. Black eyes. Well
of course in the right direction though.
Yes. That's applied to the day that
I was like, that can't be real.
That literally can't be real. His
Dick was so big. It was preposterous.
He probably had an 18 inch
dick 1818 inch deck. It was so,
and it was thick around as your
fucking risk. It was ridiculous.
There was a girl who was trying
to suck on it. I was like, see,
I don't think the girls want that.
Girls like this. I mean, I don't know,
maybe the girl was 50 pounds. I
don't think she, even if she was,
he still had a 12 inch tick,
gigantic.
It was so ridiculously big that as I was
watching this film, I was like, okay,
what's happened over the last 2030
years with porn that we've evolved to?
Yeah. He just got a lot of guys
out of a, in the recruitment. Uh,
yeah. I guess, right?
Like the perception of what a Dick was
from like, yeah, here's what I'm saying.
Like the,
there's this implant that may or may not
work that we just watched that little
commercial for. It was brutal.
Yeah. But outside of that, yeah.
What would cause like a
girl, if girls wanted bigger
boobs, they'd get a boob job.
Yeah. That's common. Yeah, we used
to that, but guys with giant Dicks,
I don't think they're getting operations.
I think these are just just a
crop of dudes with a giant Dick.
So you have a new,
a new class of guys just showed up.
Another level to Leah Dicks are so big.
This recruit and the fuck.
We've had a real great draft this
year. It's different. It's like people,
the big Dick dudes from like the
1970s and eighties they had kids with,
people ate a lot of vitamins.
Maybe it was an optical illusion
because we had more pubes back then. No,
it was coming out of the forest. You
didn't see half of no, no, no, no, no,
no. This guy was, these guys
are mass. This guy had a
snake. Yeah. It was a snake.
It was a fat snake that you would
like capturing the everglades.
This is why I kept my pants on at the
Banya. I didn't want people. Yeah.
Intimidate.
If you've got a dick like that,
you just swung that thing anywhere you
want. Whenever you want it. I'm cares.
Who Cares? Well, anyway,
I'm sure there's black white dudes
that have giant dicks too. I just,
there's a couple of not seeing them.
I'm not seeing them at the saint with
the scene. I'm just being honest.
The limited amount of research
that I've done is, uh,
there is a difference for you,
I think what your defense mechanism
was, right? Like rightly to say. Yeah.
Women don't want that. They don't
want, they try and take that hurts him.
Every time I go, I get it, bro. Come on.
I know where you're coming from. You know,
I want my ladies to be happy,
not upset.
Some girls want to be upset.
That guy,
by the way,
billionaire in his sixties yeah.
Why are you even thinking about it is
your board, why are you even these board?
Isn't that amazing?
Like if you've got that much
money's top and think about that.
You're in your sixties
you got that much money,
you have billions of dollars and
how much time do you have left?
What do you do with your money
and what do you do with your time?
You know the dude's probably
fucking bored as shit we owe.
Has it come down to sex? Go. Why not
get a hobby? You're so old timey. Look,
get this.
Each injection of hyaluronic acid fillers
costs between 250 and $750 and adds
girth.
Ro said person,
patients usually begin with
about 10 10 injections.
Injection filler injections. Whew. Wow.
Jesus Christ is not good.
The patient could have given
him general anesthesia,
which may be exacerbated a
preexisting heart conditions.
Oh Jesus Christ got heart. He had
a heart condition. This guy. Yeah.
See they live it. You know what?
Hold on. Put that back on it.
It says if you're getting
general anesthesia and you
have an underlying malady
in your heart, you will unmask
that and it will show itself.
Jesus.
People are so bored.
So all this money and it just makes you
more board ultimately. Yeah. Ridiculous.
I think people just get on a
path. Right? And what is the path?
The Path is to, to acquire success. Yeah.
And when you're doing something
like selling diamonds, you know,
congratulations for making a lot of money.
People like to buy diamonds,
but what are you doing?
What are you doing those diamonds,
and you're buying diamonds.
You selling diamonds are buying diamond,
and you're getting older and you're,
you're, you're like, oh my God,
I'm at the end of the ride. What am I
doing? What was this right about? Yeah,
I'm not dexilant big enough.
Fuck it. And why we're going in,
we're going to take anesthesia,
we're going to get it dick fixed.
But because he was just
essentially moving money around,
he wasn't making something easy.
You think that's it?
That there was no words
to what he was doing?
I think just like he wasn't being
satisfied mentally with his job,
with his work, with his life. Yeah.
I think there's probably a lot of
people in his sort of position.